Wonder Woman is still the number one
superhero movie in the country and the
film was boosted by some excellent
visual effect
we've got VFX producer amber Hirsch here
to explain how her team gave Wonder
Woman some of his glow so visual effects
were just there to enhance the story and
make Wonder Woman do the incredible
things that she can do that a normal
person couldn't do gal gadot was
incredibly you know strong and talented
and did great stunts and but there were
some things like jumping to the top of a
building that sorry but no one can do
that and so it was really fun to inspire
and enhance the story one of the most
challenging shots was a shot on the
beach battle where it had many many
layers around nine layers and we had to
shoot each of those actions the
foreground action the mid-ground the
back and nine layers deep all in
separate passes and then feather them
together and add various elements
including the whole entire background of
the clip to make the shot possible so
look up some mascara was was very
interesting because it's a place that
doesn't exist it is inspired by you know
the landscape that was shot in Italy
it's inspired by the China the mountains
of really unique mountains inspired by a
lot of the water elements and the tones
that Patti really wanted to portray it
was a long process kind of honing it all
in having enough green having enough
water and it was a really fun process to
kind of create this place that doesn't
exist and it's so beautiful and a place
that you want to go to I would say one
of the scenes that I'm most proud of for
a multitude of reasons would be no-man's
land there was a long planning process
in previs during that sequence because
it was such an important moment we saw
Diana as
woman for the first time we revealed her
costumes
we saw her power her strength her
attitude she she realized that she could
really deflect bullets and and she was
so courageous her ultimate drive and
inspiration is that she wants to help
mankind and she she fights from her
heart she does wonderful things with her
powers she helped people she's strong
she's courageous she's just so
multifaceted she is Wonder Woman and
Wonder Woman is love that's it for this
episode but don't forget to give your
home a little Wonder Woman polish with
one of the statues based on the film
from DC collectibles what an try if you
would have wanted